sadly bullying can have a long-lasting
effect on mental health and well-being
so today the diana award are raising
awareness about bullying in schools and
online and with the don't face it alone
campaign so we'll be prime minister
please join me in encouraging any young
person experiencing bullying to speak up
and speak out
can i thank him very much and uh
congratulate him on on his
own campaign on this issue i think
everybody understands that bullying is
an absolutely appalling
experience and something that we should
not tolerate in our society and i'm
delighted to see so many colleagues so
many honourable members wearing their
blue ribbons today mr speaker we should
all speak out against bullying but we
should also make sure that we give
everybody the courage and to speak out
against bullying as well
now of course usually the question
doesn't get the chance to respond to the
pm's answer but we're trying to put that
right so today
we can talk to the conservative mp for
watford dean russell who put that
question to the prime minister thank you
for being with us um you i can see
you're sporting your blue ribbon an
enormous amount of mps were doing the
same at pmqs today and what did you make
of what the prime minister said to you
well it's great to have number 10 and
the prime minister's backing of this
fantastic campaign you know the the
campaign itself is in over about two and
a half thousand schools i believe 1.5
million young people are taking part in
uk youth charity the diner awards
activities and in particular around the
don't face it alone campaign so the
opportunity to have the backing of
number 10 they did an event i believe on
monday which featured people like rio
ferdinand talking about their
experiences and their work with young
people but also the opportunity to raise
awareness and i very much appreciate you
having me
on tonight
to tell people that you know don't face
it alone.com if you go there you can get
lots of free resources schools teachers
parents lesson plans videos and really
it's about raising awareness and i was
so fortunate that mr speaker chose me as
a very last question to come in right at
the end
and share awareness of this fantastic
campaign
it's been i've been really struck with
some of the the interviews that i've
done recently and also some of the
stories that have been shared on social
media by some pretty high-profile mps
about their own experiences of bullying
and i know it can be quite a difficult
thing to talk about because it's one of
those things that people tend to kind of
bury quite deeply inside because it's
very painful
you know i spoke to nadeem zaharwe the
education secretary who was talking
about being chased around a park and
dunked under water in the pond by
bullies brandon lewis the northern
ireland secretary uh tweeting today
saying that he was bullied as a teenager
he's dyslexic he was overweight he was
seen as an easy target older kids
thought i was too stupid to succeed too
fat to be taken seriously
you know how important is it do you
think that people in these positions are
open about some of the difficulties that
they face when they were younger
i think it's incredibly important and
it's great to see colleagues be so open
about it i mean i've been campaigning on
mental health and mental well-being for
quite a while now and i was fortunate in
the session to promote the initiative in
watford that i do to train a thousand
middle health first aiders with some
fantastic organizations including the
watford and west heart uh chamber of
commerce who helped deliver that with
volunteers and and the key theme on it
all
is sharing one's experiences learning
from others talking about it and not
being afraid um to share that because i
think the challenge we've seen in
society is there is a stigma and there
has always been a stigma sadly around
mental health and in particular around
bullying and i think actually what this
campaign's trying to do is get people to
talk about it to don't face it alone as
it's called and as the uh as the the
main phrase of it but actually what it's
about is to speak out but also to speak
up and if you're seeing bullying in the
school or your friends and someone's
struggling because of it you know
support them speak up about it and let
people know because
invariably
when i've ever i've spoken to children
about this in young people when they do
make that move actually it totally
removes the bully's power okay um and
actually the power that the bullies
often have is to keep people silenced
and keep them you know so in their
control and actually that's where you
can speak up and and diminish
really important thank you so much
coming on a really important interview
to give thank you